good morning guys morning coffee
thoughts except a quick coffee
but I still drink chai tea I'm sorry
I'm sorry I couldn't do it
that's next coffee I eliminated first
okay and I have I haven't had coffee
but yeah the chai tea oh no this is
messy what the hell you see this
they didn't even give me napkins oh they
did they did they give me two
oh shoot I was gonna eat and talk to you
guys
and then you guys are always like oh
well don't do it while you eat and I'm
like well sometimes that's the only time
I have okay
okay guys so a couple updates with the
channel so
first of all this year
I think I'm gonna do less shows on two
shows a week do some documentaries and I
have some ideas for the next year of
things I want to put out and I want to
ask you guys opinion and advice
um
okay
so I'd like to do an event this year for
a million
to celebrate right
um I think I'm gonna do it in London
because that's like where we did the
show I want to invite all the show
guests have a lot of fun
um
I need to make my talent get to a
hundred thousand Subs that's one of my
goals this year
um
I want to put out a course how to get 2
million subscribers right
um
but for the events this is what I'm
excited about
okay
and I think we're gonna make a website
this year
so I also want to make enough money so I
can get a CEO
yeah so if you're a CEO
DM me you know what I mean because I
can't do it it can't be me women
shouldn't be in charge
remember my dad said to get a good one
he gave me a number of what you'd have
to afford
and I want the CEO to just deal with all
the problems and not me
but I can give my creative genius right
anyways um
like I'd be the owner they'd be the
that's what I learned Okay so
so today I'm talking about
something I noticed in the dating market
so before I'm gonna tell you about this
I'm gonna eat a piece of my sandwich I
know you guys hate watching me I don't
care
oh my God that's so messy
I think I remember I'll wait maybe I'll
wait
um
so
what I've noticed is the men and women
are mad and they're mad for different
reasons okay the men
say to the women
you guys aren't virgins anymore
I mean they won't tell you this to your
face but this is what they're thinking
you're not virgins anymore you guys are
fat
um you're not even loyal to get your ass
on Instagram and you're asking me to
marry you
and the thing is most men want to get
married most men are willing to marry
girls a little overweight most men are
willing to marry a girl that
has a lot of body like honestly I'm just
being real here most men are gonna
Overlook that stuff it's not their
preference
but
most men and by a lot of bodies is
subjective but I'm saying by 1950
standards okay most men are gonna wife a
girl that slept with more than three
people I'm sorry
I'm sorry
but most men from what I've I've asked
except about 10. this is just the market
I don't make the rules please I'm not
please don't come for me please please
this is just what the guys are saying so
and by 10 they mean 20.
anyways anyways anyways
um
so so the guys are willing to accept
this
now
however there's a caveat I need to watch
you
and make sure that you're a good bet so
it's not so risky because I'm me as a
guy getting married today
it's a bad trade-off right I don't
really get the best car but I want to
make sure this car stays loyal to me I
don't believe this analogy probably
doesn't work but
so let me make sure there's no factory
defaults there's no nothing under the
hood that goes wrong so I'm gonna drive
this car
for three years before I get the
lifetime warranty I don't know
and the reason the guys are doing this
is to offset the risk of marriage today
marriage is risky they've seen one or
two guys get divorced so they want to
date you for like three to five years
and this is typical with what I've seen
in real life most of the people that I
know like my brothers my brother got
married after 10 years that was a little
extreme you know who you are
um and the other one got married after
like three
or four I don't know he's been dating
this girl for a while she's been around
for a couple Christmases
um
that's what they do to offset the wrist
but on the other hand the women were
training youth and Purity so like every
time we date a guy we run the risk of
of you know it's an extra person that
you slept with it's an extra I'll give
you an example I've never lived with a
guy if I were to live with a guy now
that's something and it didn't work out
that's something I did with him that I
would also do with hypothetically my
husband right so it's like we're running
the risk of doing things with you that
we can't give to our husband we're
running the risk which I know each girl
it's different but what percent of girls
are waiting until they're married
not many so I'm talking in modern times
okay and
then we have
youth right so it's like okay you got
two years of my youth or three years of
my youth and the women get increasingly
anxious each year that we put gave you
our youth
we gave you our Purity and it's not
gonna work out and we're not gonna get
what we want which is long-term
commitment and the men are like you know
what I want to wait longer and longer to
marry you because I want to offset the
risk of marriage and so that's why the
men and the women the women will say
things like oh if he loved you he'd
marry you and sometimes the men will
play into this because the men will say
oh well real like men that want to get
married get married in six months or
less that could be true that's just not
what I've noticed because again most of
the guys that I know
that are getting married loved their
girlfriends and wanted to get married
they just want to do it on their time
and the women that's what we get
increasingly neurotic each year that's
why you see these women like begging
these guys to marry them like like
pulling them or whatever
and it's just not an affair
I mean it is a fair exchange I mean it's
not fair the women are always get more
out of it but the men are trying to make
it more fair
they're like okay I don't want to get
this girl pregnant and
yeah that's that's what I've noticed
um
second thing I'm sorry I'm off the ball
I was gonna talk about this earlier but
I forgot
second thing
you know actually no so another thing I
learned this week
was
oh God
when we always talk about the
consenting
to sex right like
birth control why did birth control
change the game birth control changed
the game
because it was the only way that men
could have sex with someone but not
consent
to the contraception that's being used
so like for example
if a guy they always put the
responsibility on the men why aren't you
wearing a condom right
true okay y'all should stop wilding in
these streets but
why aren't you wearing a condom but the
thing is the girl agrees she knows he's
wearing a condom during the sex right so
she knows what's happening
on the other hand the men
can consent to sex with a girl that says
she has an IUD on birth control she
could lie
and he is therefore consenting to sex
that like he's not
like both both parties aren't aware of
what's going on and they both like she
only knows that's why she has more power
because
yeah because he is consenting to sex
with her on birth control and she could
not be on birth control that's why she
has more power in that situation
like it's kind of like
I mean and and it's weird because it
used to be so common to like encourage
this from
women like they'd be like lie to your
husband say you're on the pill and get
pregnant it's like what
what y'all are crazy
um
okay other thing the event I was gonna
say this earlier but I forgot the event
I have an idea for events for like red
pill people and so this is what we could
do imagine
imagine
live debates
um we get some super Libs shout out you
know Destiny
um
put an event together wear them
you can buy let's say we have one event
a quarter or something
and it's like three days I mean it's
literally debates for three days
straight and then after there's like I
don't know dinners or like
a party I don't know and you can get a
subscription like season pass for all
four events
you can buy the meet and greets you can
buy
behind the scenes and it would be like
let's say we got
I don't know Donovan me lead attorney
MTR and then we got
I don't know Brittany Lee
Destiny I don't know some some left or
modern
thinking
type things
and yeah we just battle it out and
debate have a party after
I was like this would be fun like no
one's really done events in the
in the
space I think to the
fullest extent that we could
um let me know what you guys think of
that in the comments I also thought
about traveling from City to city but
that sounds like so much work
also for the course
if you're a business owner I'm just
curious what would you pay
to have me
do your entire back end of your YouTube
channel I'm talking about thumbnails
send you a producer editing what would
you pay a month
for me to do everything for you
and what would you pay
for a course how to get a million
subscribers in a year Well I talk about
the systems that I built I talk about
how to hire people I talk about the
analytics I have um my nerd front
the Nerds uh
that'll go into the analytics because I
don't really understand a lot of them
um
yeah and like a course how much would
you pay for that and how much would you
pay for events because I'm trying to
figure out
it's it's like I have so many ideas that
could make money and could be really
good but I have to figure out what is
worth my time because I have I have too
many good ideas anyways like the video
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time